this next comic is responsible for most
of my wrinkles caused by all the laugh
lines
you think i was on the floor
hello everybody yes thank you for
clicking the link thank you for watching
here at home uh congratulations to you
watching this because you know what we
got through a pandemic
yeah we did that it's a lot to deal with
i mean
we we we had to learn how to zoom
that was the thing my mom had her first
zoom doctor meeting recently and i sat
in with my mom just to help her out
45 minutes go by we're done we closed
the laptop i looked to my mom and go mom
what'd you think and she looks at me and
goes who was that guy
adorable just adorable i had a zoom
doctor meeting as well
when to get an eye exam apparently you
can't do that in person
because you know covered but
i did it over zoom and it was great
apparently my new
prescription is 720p 1080p
doctor said he'll get me back to 4k no
time so we'll see
a little skeptical about it but you know
we'll see uh
big shout out to all the students out
there who made it work for a whole year
they they went through school through
zoom i don't know how you did it
props to you guys uh to the parents
props to you guys but
you know what it's been a tough year
let's save some money don't buy a
yearbook for your student this year
you know what you do go over and
screenshot
the zoom class save that as a pdf
and have your student send it out to all
its friends
and they can sign it digitally and
that's it you save 100 bucks so you're
welcome that's on the house free tip
there
um yeah quarantine was was was difficult
for everybody for me
i got to do everything i wanted to do
and never got a chance to do like i read
books i saw movies i cleaned my belly
button
i recommend doing that had sand in there
like when was the last time i went to
the beach
i had a cubic zirconia growing in there
also blue lint it reminded me is like
what happened
to that blue sweater i like that one
i gotta watch that said again let's
rewind
that comedian knows how to work a crowd
am i right